hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong the podcast
hosted by myself and my esteemed co-host
miss jacqueline coley jacqueline we're
back everybody's listening and this is i
like i don't make these grand
proclamations all that often this might
be
the toughest task we've ever had here in
the many decades we've been doing rotten
tomatoes is wrong how you doing
yeah i mean the source material for this
is like 20 years old let alone the show
which is like a you know good old decade
yeah we've got a lot to walk through on
this one lot of walking did you get a
nap in today no and i need one but i'm
i'm here with you which is like a shot
of caffeine
i've never heard myself described as
that so i will take it i did get my nap
in which is probably why i feel so awake
right now and you mentioned that we're
gonna be walking and
jaclyn made that joke because it
references what we're talking about
today everyone it is the walking dead
now most podcast jaclyn would say okay
let's do one season of walking dead and
call it a day uh not here not a rotten
tomatoes is wrong we are doing the
entire
run of the walking dead all is the 20th
is to carry the one 10 seasons of
walking dead that have aired thus far
we're going to be doing it all you me
and our esteemed guests i have a fun
fact i have many fun facts about the
walking dead here's one it was created
by robert kirkman like you said almost
20 years ago in 2003 but it took seven
years for the show to debut on amc
december 31st 2010 we were in between
christmas and new year's and we got
zombies or excuse me walkers as they're
called in 2018 the walking dead received
an award for being the most in-demand
series
ever
by
some award body in miami where they
study all these different sort of
metrics that say that no this is the
show that people want to watch where
they're watching it live or they're
streaming it however they're doing it
this is the show that people want to see
the most and for all of our listeners
and viewers out there at rotten tomatoes
we have an article that is every episode
of the walking dead ranked by tomato
meter because we love the tomato movie
here so i encourage you all to go check
out that article on the site but look
we're gonna do a sweeping broad analysis
but also get in depth with some of our
favorite episodes from our favorite
season some of our favorite characters
where we think rotten tomatoes in that
beloved tomato meter may be right or
wrong with walking dead over its 10
illustrious seasons and to do that
jacqueline we've recruited a
guest who is somewhat of a conundrum now
look
he hails from pittsburgh he's he's one
of pennsylvania's favorite sons he
hosted a show on the history channel
called eating history he's a star okay
one day he's going to be hosting a
popular trivia show where they give you
the answer and you have to respond with
a question but until then he is one of
the founding members of the good people
association network you can find all
their stuff in podcast form and on
youtube he is the host of the daily
positivity report as well as his spin on
said classic trivia show josh birdie he
is my dear friend josh mccooga josh
you're here
and look
it's know why the hell of an introvert
on the show but
jacqueline here's why he's a conundrum
is because josh bakuga is maybe the most
fraidy cat individual i've ever met in
my entire life and he has made a cottage
industry out of scaring himself for the
pleasure of the rest of the world josh
you play vr horror games you watch
horror movies all because you we know
it's going to scare the crap out of you
and we enjoy watching it so as somebody
who sat next to you when we saw it
which was not a fun experience for me no
that's my bad um
why the walking dead
yeah you know uh
i tried to watch that uh
28 days or weeks or months later you
know the one with the zombies uh and
that scared the living crap out of me
and then um i watched uh you know being
from pittsburgh uh romero george romero
you know night of the living dead he's
from pittsburgh shot in pittsburgh so i
was like you know what zombies maybe
deserve a second chance and then
everybody wouldn't shut up about the
walking dead you got to watch the
walking dead and i was watching mad men
on amc all the programming i'm
programming on amc and i was like you
know what the zombies the walkers
whatever you want to call them it's not
for me and then all of a sudden like
right around the beginning of season
three i was like all right you know what
i gotta host tv talk on collider i need
to know about the walking dead i gotta
act like i care about these walkers and
then all of a sudden i was hooked i
liked the walkers i thought that they
there wasn't a lot of jump scares it was
more about like the human condition
and dealing with a world with walkers
and then i thought to myself how long
would i survive in this and i would have
been dead season one episode two but i
need to see where humanity goes with all
of these walkers and then
like a true pittsburgher
i've invested way too much time into
this basket right like i have put all of
my effort into a team like the
pittsburgh pirates who will year in and
year out lose every single year but
guess what i'm sticking until the end
because one day one of the it will pay
off and the walking dead
it has its payoffs it has its let's
downs it's like relationships in your
20s
just kind of got to keep weathering it
until you find somebody in your 30s that
makes you happy just keep playing
jacqueline i i feel like you and i are
on the same page with walking dead
because i feel like you and i both uh
put in our dues so to speak where i
didn't necessarily get tired of watching
the show because i was a loyal viewer
from the beginning of it all the way i
think through see the end of or middle
of season eight and then i was just like
i think i'm done here
is that your experience as well
yeah no i was one of the people that i
think amc could just classify all of us
together of the people that pretty much
jumped shift right after glenn died um
that was uh that was when i was done in
fact i went to i used to go to sunday
night walking dead watch parties at the
jackalope in austin
and i even like the jacqueline at the
jackalope yeah
that's exactly what happened and i
remember recording it was me and my best
friend our reaction to the finale not
where we find out glenn is dead but the
finale where they do the baseball bat
and then they fake you out
i recorded that and i was livid and like
if that video is somewhere like you
literally see me do full on nerd rants
um and then i like kind of kept in with
the next episode and
i stopped wanting to watch because of
the astro show it just became an ickier
endeavor
there's a whole lot to look forward to
in this episode we're doing things a
little different today so right now what
we are going to do is go to our expert
review curation manager tim ryan at
rotten tomatoes he's the one that sifted
through 10 seasons of reviews from
critics from audience from everyone and
their mother especially ones that live
in pittsburgh and he sifted through
these to give us the highlights for a
segment we call two minutes with tim
[Music]
you know any show that's been on the air
for 10 seasons bound to have its ups and
downs but by and large the walking dead
has been able to keep things relatively
steady at least from a critical
standpoint the overall score for the
series is 80 with a 78 audience score
when it debuted in 2010 the series
started strong it's certified fresh with
an 87 tomato meter and the rotten
tomatoes critic's consensus reads
blood spattered emotionally resonant and
white knuckle intense the walking dead
puts an intelligent spin on the
overcrowded zombie sub genre
subsequently the best reviewed season
was the 9th it's certified fresh with a
91 tomato meter and the lowest reviewed
were the 7th and 8th seasons which are
both at 64 percent the most recent
season season 10 is certified fresh at
83 percent so what did the critics have
to say in a fresh review from season 9
patrick gomez of entertainment weekly
wrote the world of the walking dead is
still a scary and dangerous place
however in a rotten review from season
eight christy turnquist of portland's
oregonian wrote the action is so
fragmented it often feels like to
paraphrase shakespeare there's a lot of
sound and fury going on and it doesn't
signify much so anyway that's the
walking dead and on a personal note i
cashed out when my favorite character
was killed off no spoilers but i will
say i think about the last moment of the
first season when a gigantic explosion
at a government facility is scored to
bob dylan's tomorrow is a long time man
that still gives me chills and so
you you hear that
tim talk about this and i agree
with the fact that people either love
this show or they don't necessarily hate
it josh they just feel like i think i've
put in my time here and i'm gonna move
on to something else but there are loyal
defenders of the show now and i count
you amongst their ranks heading into the
announced final season 11. i don't i
this isn't kind of like one of those
things where oh i i was a fan even
through the dark like no no okay listen
i knew dave matthews band when they were
playing in williamsburg virginia bars
listen i oar played my front lawn in
college
hey you know what twilight episode was
me and
me and her just having a great time this
is gonna be that episode for me and i'm
okay with this
jacqueline jacqueline's name is very
hard to say in the pittsburgh accent
because we have a lot of trouble saying
an l after an o so it's like jacqueline
coy
it's really tough
so
so anyway so like when everybody jumped
ship i jacqueline i understand your
vitriol for the finale where we just saw
blood come down on a camera and we got
nothing else but a summer's worth of
people being like it's glenn
it's gotta be glenn oh it's abraham oh
no it's gonna be coral oh what if it's
so like everybody had their own theory
on as to who the bat smashed their head
in and put a solid dent like you know
crazy joe divola and seinfeld but
what
i thought was are you shocked by that we
knew that that's how it was going to end
you knew how that season was going to
end so you you like that this show kind
of it kind of it takes you by the hand
guys who then also throws curveballs at
you correct the bottom line here it's
the only show like game of thrones where
they will
kill off main characters often wait a
minute though the game of thrones didn't
like fade to black right before the red
wedding um they did stab jon snow at the
end of the season and then wait for
another season to bring him back to life
we'll bring both of you back for game of
thrones talk but we're focusing on the
walking dead and to help us focus is now
the chore that i am so happy is not mine
it is going to the young lady who needs
a nap anyway and she really is gonna
need one after this because jacqueline
i hate to do this to you i i need a
synopsis of of walking dead um and if
you feel like breaking down seasons and
characters and storyline you know what
i'm just gonna turn it over to you
do your thing
all right so bear with me on this one
i'm gonna try to do the best i can but
we're gonna talk about the television
adaptation of the walking dead we open
season one with rick grimes a police
officer who wakes up in a hospital after
being in a coma for several months and
wakes up literally right in the middle
of the zombie apocalypse outside of
atlanta he has no idea where his family
is at and he sort of just gets on a
horse gets his uh his shotgun after sort
of stumbling around and realizing that
zombies have taken over the second
season it turns out one of the people
that rick meets up with is shane this
was his partner during the
when he was a police officer and he was
shane was actually the one who locked
him up in a room when the zombies were
taking over and he realized that rick
was too sick to make it out on his own
but he knew that he did want to give him
at least a chance he bars the door goes
back to laurie and carl and says hey
rick is dead and sort of takes on as a
pseudo
father and is having sex with lori at
the time that rick shows back up setting
him up to be the villain of season two
and eventually he is because rick stabs
him in the chest when he realizes
there's no point in which shane is going
to put himself lower he's going to think
that he should be the leader when in
actuality it is rick it is almost if i'm
ever in a hospital please don't do that
with my family thanks buddy exactly
no promises the apocalypse a long time
exactly
i'm skipping the farm because nobody
cares all you need to know is glenn and
maggie hook up that was a long long
season let me let me give you the farm
season in a real quick season we got to
go to town for supplies somebody got
eaten yes exactly i'm not going to tell
you about the farm the farm is dumb just
know they spent time on a farm and then
we head into season three and season
three is where we really figure out that
humans are more dangerous than the
zombies the groups the group has kind of
banded together
and they realize that they're able to
fight zombies they've got their fighters
they've got their smart folks they know
kind of how to i think deal with things
they find a prison which is helpful
because lori rick's wife is pregnant and
they're trying to find a safe place for
her to have the baby but it is also at
that time that they meet the governor
who is the first big bad of the walking
dead he's got an eye patch
governor shows up at the prison starts
killing a bunch of people including
herschel chops off his head and now the
group yet again
is
put in a situation where they don't
necessarily know where they're going to
be and what uh
what they're going to do to save
themselves they're trying to find
shelter yet again they're back on the
road and that is where we kick off with
season five and this is walking dead at
its heyday no sanctuary is the first
season of that this is also the season
where we get the iconic line we are the
walking dead up until this point in the
series everyone assume the walking dead
is the zombies we come to realize that
it is actually the people who are
walking the earth because he also
divulges the fact that everybody is
infected the disease that causes people
to be zombies is with every single
person and the minute that they die
they're going to turn into zombies a key
point that you're going to see a lot
throughout the series as people die by
maybe gunshot and then come back as
zombies to kill each other after
terminus after the hospital the two
groups come together they've picked up a
couple a couple of other people and they
make their way to alexandria this is
season six alexandria
alexandria virginia is the closest that
you can honestly say you are to some
form of safety the second half of the
alexandria season is where we meet do
you need some water no we're gonna make
it negan
negan is the big bad that is going to
primarily be the villain probably for
the next three seasons and all you need
to know is he is if rick grimes is good
he is bad and as bad as bad can be and
he has a bat named lucille
negan takes his bat lucille bangs glenn
in the head maggie his wife is really
upset because she's about to have his
baby and well really upset is a good
yeah yeah that's a good way of putting
it yes she wasn't thrilled with the turn
of events wasn't thrilled with the turn
of events probably one of the biggest
moments of the series is where a lot of
people jump ship in season seven negan
is also really evil but at certain
points during the season the alexandria
folks are working for them trying to
plot their way to figure out what they
can do and where they can go and just
when you think our alexandria folks are
about to go up against negan
here come the whispers in season 9.
these people are zombies
what we think are zombies at the
beginning of their introduction but
they're really people that put on zombie
bodies they masquerade as zombies and
kill
a lot of our survivors they are probably
the scariest people in the world they
all band together and eventually
negan does prove himself to be a member
of the group that they want to keep with
him in season 10 when he kills alpha
who's one of that
woman he slept with who by the way when
he slept with her she did not take off
her zombie mask yes no zombie sex so
just to give you a recap on rick's kids
he had carl who we meet at the beginning
of the series he gets bit during one of
the attacks with um the whisperers but
his daughter judith during season nine
which is right before we get to the last
season that they had there is a six year
jump rick has left the compound michonne
is running everything judith has grown
up and daryl is now um daryl and negan
are now a part of the group and maggie
is really not happy about that idea
because again
negan bashed her husband's head in with
a baseball bat and so when we start
season 11
we have daryl taking off with carol
you have maggie back on the show after
she disappeared for a while rick has
been lifted by a helicopter we have no
idea where the heck he is and we're
trying to decide
where negan the group and everyone is
going to be as they meet a group of
individuals with really awesome suits
that are their new villains and that's
who we're going to be taking on in
season 11. i tried my best
y'all whoo
in case you can't tell the later seasons
the ones i didn't watch
but
that's it
that was an epic recap where you got all
the pertinent information in there you
mispronounced rick's son's name it's
actually coral but
you you nailed everything and i i think
that you set us up perfectly to get into
this let's have some tv talk
[Music]
first of all
congratulations on all your success that
was absolutely fantastic maybe the best
synopsis we've ever had on the show yeah
i mean it really it was hard i just want
to say because i know y'all are going to
be like messaging lucy she forgot this
person and that wasn't what that person
did
give the girl a break you did way more
than what i was expecting i thought you
were just gonna list off the locations
and the villains each no
i wanted you to give you some beats give
you that's awesome this is basically
like if you were trying to get the news
from someone that only got the cliff
notes of the news
that's what i gave you
yeah jaclyn's who you want to see if you
didn't read the book you know she didn't
read the book but she knows more about
the book than you do and so now we try
to give the book report but i mean like
to be fair this is walking dead and so i
think combined we've probably sucked
through this show as loyal viewers for
26 seasons because jaclyn's probably a
good eight i'm a good eight josh is all
10 seasons so josh i want to start with
you do you have a favorite season well
season eight and season nine together
are the best the walking dead ever was
in all of the seasons in my in my
opinion i think that uh negan it like
the the the turn around of negan because
i'll be honest i hated negan as a
villain not like hated him because he
was evil hated him because it was like
this
i'm at karaoke performance of what a
villain is supposed to be like
rick
i'm a oh god a bat it's like nobody
talks like that right i'm guessing that
a lot of you fine folks thought i was
dead chewed up never to be crapped out
again
well
here's a little refresher on who the
hell i am i wear a leather jacket i have
lucille and my nutsack is made of steel
i am not dying until i am
good and ready and then
then you had uh the mom from in america
come uh and be alpha right and samantha
morton yeah all of a sudden samantha
morton goes from like i'm your mother to
being like oh
i'm a villain right but at least they
they were a little more threatening than
just negan with a bat right and it was
when she
when beta kind of took over beta is the
best
like all-around you can't kill him
villain because he didn't say anything
and it's gary bertier from uh remember
the titans yeah
so that's season eight and nine there's
so many different character developments
happening
there's the the villains are
legit
terrifying because you don't know where
they are whereas negan we were
constantly like searching them out and
then they'd like appear somewhere and
then they'd kidnap somebody and it was
fine and you knew eventually they were
gonna get negan because rick kept
telling you time and time again i'm
gonna kill you i'm gonna kill you while
sweat drips down his face and the same
shirt he always wore right like that
just got old whereas alpha and beta and
the whisperers you had they had their
her daughter and their talk about a
crazy relationship obviously a lot of
therapy needed for that young girl um
but you had all these whispers always
appearing everywhere but what they did
so well in seasons eight nine was they
used the herd they used the herd our
original villain the walkers they used
the walkers bring back the walkers i was
tired of seeing some back country
militia warfare give me the walkers
that's what we signed up for in this
show okay so instead of uh a guy with a
bat and like a bunch of people dressed
like wolves and whatever
you now had the walkers as their main
enemy and they kept trying to move the
herd and that's where my love of weird
weapons in the walking dead could have
really come to fruition and we had like
that medieval sort of slant where i mean
you talk about ross marquan's character
now it literally just is wielding like a
warning star on his left hand which is
pretty awesome as shocked as i am that
josh didn't pick season 10 simply
because that's the one where i believe
we we hang out in pittsburgh for a
little bit it seems like season eight
and nine for you josh
you are more of a fan of the
matriculation of negan as an actual
fleshed-out character who's complicated
as opposed to just the stock villain i
ca so i don't want to put words in your
mouth but season eight is 64 percent on
the tomato meter and that's one of the
lowest seasons that might be the one
that is tied for the lowest season
season seven and eight 64
yeah but nobody watched them that's why
no because nobody watched
that's what jaclyn and i jump ship so
jaclyn do you go further back i assume
than josh's favorite season
yeah i mean because like again y'all
that the like basically
of season seven eight and nine from my
recap are
partially watched but mostly from
youtube recaps of what i was able to see
and a couple of quote videos so i have
no idea half of this stuff had happened
i did know about the wolves i did know
about like simon and that kind of stuff
so i was there for that little bit but
for me the fifth season because i was
actually a fan of the comics so like i
was deep into this comics run i remember
i bought the what i mean i i checked out
from my public library
the walking dead volume one which was
the weekly comic sort of bounded
together
um before the show was even a thing and
i was breezing through that and so i was
ahead of the show for like a long time
but as the show started deviating i was
just like i don't have time for that and
then i moved out here and comics pretty
much became that thing i used to do
before i had to do movies for a living
but season five
when rick has that moment in the shed
where he says we are the walking dead
that is to me some of the greatest
comic book easter egg crossover moments
because that's not a big moment as far
as a cool quote there's way more quotes
from the show that people will be like
look at the flowers sweetie and you know
they mess with the wrong ones those are
more show quotes the we are the walking
dead quote was like the one where i felt
every bit of what i loved about the
comic
come into the show but no matter what we
find in dc i know we'll be okay
because this is how we
survive
[Music]
we tell ourselves
that we
are the walking dead
for people that didn't know that the
show was called walking dead i remember
being on the internet and people were
like oh my god they're the walking dead
like like there was a lot of people who
had never made that connection
and you're just sitting in your house
like just nodding like no nodding but
excited i've been waiting for it i was
like i know they're gonna pull this turn
you know because like
is that like the jaclyn at home kind of
like that family guy moment like ah ah
oh i mean i was [ __ ] i was more
leonardo dicaprio and once upon a time
in hollywood like that you know okay but
um but it was good great gifts yeah it
was it was really good and also because
they called them walkers that was also
the part that really helped solidify the
idea that you thought the zombies were
the walking dead do you know what like
really kind of sold me on the entire
show is obviously in the pilot when you
see that like he's walking through the
park and he sees that zombie like trying
to get him that's cut in half
and it's just like a body with no legs
i'm like okay let's just say i got a
little too drunk at barney's one night
i had too much jack daniels i wake up
and the world is now zombies
that's where i would be like oh
shoot like look at all this i the one
night i decided to do this
one night but now like you wake up in
this hospital you don't know where the
world is that is where it messes with
the actual human psyche of everything
and that's why i think i was so invested
in the show from here on out because
you don't know what the world is going
to look like in this world and the one
that robert kirkman created as soon as
the walkers took over the only people
that survived were bad people yeah yeah
very much yeah and every time we're so
conditioned as audiences to be like okay
well there's this evil supernatural like
presence that is attacking us we gotta
we gotta pack together we gotta find
other humans to for their safety in
numbers and it's like no the more
numbers you have on walking dead the
more danger there is because humans at
their heart are pretty awful people
especially when we're trying to survive
a zombie apocalypse would it all been
presented if everybody took a vaccine i
don't want to get into that honestly
let the tea the real tea
i just also want to say this though too
about like what i i like i think i would
like about the later seasons is
by about season seven we realized that
these characters who we love
um are great and invested in and we
don't want anything bad to happen to
them are villains in a lot of other
people's stories totally and
that part and the negan arc i think kind
of makes that
come to fruition the scene where maggie
sees negan again and
and
he's just like hey man
he's like this is gonna be a long
conversation this might be several
conversations that we have yeah
it's like seeing your ex the next day in
high school after she broke up with you
on the phone the night before but like a
billion times worth yeah it's pretty bad
it's pretty bad when that's the guy who
bashed your husband's face in with a uh
baseball bat but i go even further back
than you all so josh season i'm gonna
give you season eight slash nine which
is one of the lowest and the highest
rated on the tomato meter so i average
out is that's like one percent it's the
end of eight and all of nine basically
yeah i mean you need that that little
set up for season nine to really have
the punch for jacqueline your season's
90 so i imagine you think rotten
tomatoes is right i tend to agree with
rotten tomatoes for my favorite season
which i'm gonna defend season two just
because i loved as much as it was like
oh there's more dead people in a farm
and we got to do something i just love
love love watching shane and rick try to
figure this whole thing out and they
kept zombies in a barn they kept zombies
in a barn and it was unfortunate and we
lost some good people but my favorite
season is actually season three which is
88
because the prison and then into
woodbury woodbury is the is the town
that i want to live in look is the
politician the governor that runs it
evil yes are politicians in real life
evil yeah so we know this so just accept
it that some of the powers that be
aren't the best of human beings but also
woodbury is the closest that we got to
like having a starbucks in this
post-apocalyptic setting and so woodbury
is what i gravitated towards because i
like that even though they're zombies
and the world as we know it is gone we
still can have nice things if only
for a little while here's the here's the
one thing about the governor
is he's probably my favorite villain
in my in my least favorite story lines
in the show because i hated the prison i
hate that they were just like waiting
around for the governor then the
governor shows up in a tank which is
awesome we live in different cell blocks
we never have to see each other until
we're all ready
it could work
you know it could
it could've
but it can't
not after woodbury
not after andrea
look i'm not saying it's going to be
easy
the fact is it's going to be a hell of a
lot harder than
standing here shooting at each other
but i don't think we have a choice
we don't
you do
but the governor is the only villain in
the show that didn't talk like he was a
villain
in a cartoon right
because they all were the only one that
was on there before it became a thing
every other actor that was hired after
that knew they were walking into 17
million views yeah no and i will and 100
agree with you on that it's just a shame
that like every time we got a villain
after that they were a caricature of a
villain from negan to alpha who just
like talked really weird even to jacinda
or what was her name oh yeah i forgot
about her the trash chick the trash
chick yeah
who's your least favorite villain josh
so if your favorite villain is the
governor who would you say out of all
the seasons and then jack and i'll get
your take who's the least favorite
villain
oh terminus the like they're that whole
season of us chasing yeah joe at
terminus it was like such a throwaway
thing if we didn't have terminus explode
via daryl and carol right if we didn't
have it explode that would have been the
biggest waste because that whole season
was legit walking without the beth death
and and
the explosion that whole that whole
season is one-off walking episode true
that jacqueline how about you favorite
least favorite villain i think my least
favorite villain would be the police
girl karen
from that same season um i don't
remember what her name was but she was
like karen before karen was personified
dawn
yeah yeah and like
she was being mean to the guy that
played chris from everybody hates chris
tyler and i was just like i was not
about that girl and just
at least with some of the dudes and i'm
not saying that every or even with alpha
you could see where they got people to
like
get on their team i'm like [ __ ] nobody
was on your team nobody was on your team
ever
ever not once yeah yeah so um yeah if
i'm going like it's hard for me i can't
really pin them as a villain even though
this show would try to make us not trust
this person from time to time but i just
never liked this character and i don't
know why maybe y'all can figure it out
the the character of jesus in the
walking dead not the bible guy bible guy
is great the character of jesus in this
show
never got it
never understood the appeal and jack
when you made a face i mean i'm not
gonna blame this on your gender but the
lady's listening to this who knows what
jesus looks like they will jesus is like
5'4 and he jump punched a zombie
he jump kicked a zombie which is legend
i'ma let y'all have this one and i'll
let the internet take care of it for me
i don't even need to argue this for you
because
he was like he's fine josh you know that
that character was loved everybody loved
course everybody loved jesus yes he was
adorable he was this cute little
long-haired guy
ladies love jesus what would jesus do he
would hack he would hook up with a lot
of the fans of the walking dead no they
love daryl they they love a
i never understood because i love norman
reedus um
but
on this show he looks like showers are
very optional he was the original
non-bathing celebrity even
even the lead singers of half of the
grunge bands in the 90s are looking at
him like brock get a shower the hair
eats a lot david perner from soul asylum
is like dude i think you need to get the
circus hose out yeah the character so
jesus is also my answer for the for my
personal award your most tedious
character like the one that you're like
look i get that you're on the show and
and congrats on booking it who's the
who's the character josh that you're
like i'm ready for your arc to be done
and so we can move on from you i would
have said carol until
i had i've had that relationship with
carol
but but that's seasons and seasons ago i
love the fact that carol and daryl now
get their own spin-off i am so
stone-cold a fan of carol
i also
like morgan even though he really wasn't
on the show so tedious michonne michonne
at points is so tedious now uh
like she yeah she just like i i never
understood i love her with a ninja sword
when she's killing everybody it's
awesome when they try to get into her
psyche of why she's doing it i'm very
bored by all that cause let me just give
me death i want to see them kill
everything okay so for my story arcs and
the care like ah so many of like the
best thing with her mental i like all
i g i get it i get that we have to have
depth to our character but really just
start killing everybody and that's where
like
when when maggie comes back she seems to
be like i'm back and i'm killing
everybody i'm like great i didn't really
want to go into the maggie backstory
whereas negan when you meet his wife and
everything you're like okay we needed a
little negan origin story but when he
was killing everybody the show was way
more entertaining to me
all like the tedious side angles of like
oh they're having a mental breakdown oh
they're back oh they're having a mental
breakdown oh they're back is what made
this show so hard to watch sometimes
over and over again and that's the
reason come on we went through this
similar thing and all we had to do was
not be able to go to the movies for 18
months like i mean legitimately
i don't blame that it seems weird if
they didn't have it i know but who's
your team's character jacqueline father
gabriel i've never understood while he's
alive and i love that actor he was great
in um starship troopers he's done like
yeah he's amazing i
want to stab him in both those eyes why
is he breathing he's awake batman and
doors he is just the worst with doors
are you saying that the fact that
because i thought it got very
interesting once you started sleeping
around
so now he's just infecting women with
his bad penis along with his bad
decisions no
no
possible like i think it's this whole
idea that he was a priest and so now
he's getting some it makes wait what's
wrong with his penis nothing
i'm just saying that it's attached to
him oh
he's not a catholic priest he's like
he's like british he's like he's like
evangelical yeah he's one of the guys
that gets to like get married and stuff
i mean i guess but it still doesn't
matter like i guess my whole thing is is
that
that's just not who i wanted to pair up
with like can we all agree that coral
was the most tedious character for that
i look my hot take in all of this is
that i think you could accuse rick of
being the most tedious character simply
because if you go with josh mccooga and
you say that i what i really don't like
about this show is when we have to go
through all these subplots of characters
having mental breakdowns nobody does
more crazy eyes or looks or trying to
reckon with the moment than talking to
people who've been dead for four seasons
yeah
rick has those things i mean if if
people know me in real life you would
say obviously mark your most tedious
character is judith because why are we
having babies in the apocalypse when
we're running from walkers
humans are really old people or or
babies so
maybe at least the old at least herschel
was a doctor and he could help us out
like judith is useless i know she comes
back and i actually liked the reviews
she's like the girl in bear island yeah
she's yeah
i just went during the prison i i wanted
nothing to do with
with judith being born why are we
wasting our time here
uh abraham i think said it best what do
you say
when you were laying the batter where
you're trying to make pancakes
as long as it's called raising the
steaks
there's a child
it's always every zombie
post-apocalyptic movie we have to have a
couple that has a kid because that's
the proliferation of the species we have
to save humanity i get it i get it
couldn't we have just gotten to virginia
first and like seen if the internet
still exists before we we're lugging
kids through multiple state lines
yeah that's a lot of trust in humanity
not banging yeah they're stressed out
they're gonna do it right even the
priests are banging yeah i didn't even
talk about the like
numerous
black characters that they killed for
reasons
like there was an entire run in love
with sasha she i thought she had a good
death she had a great day i'm not saying
about their death but i just remember so
many of them like t-dog and c-dog
yeah like what's the guy with the
hammer's name i always forget his name i
don't remember and he was awesome yeah
there was a just a tyrese like um
yeah there was so many um folks that
just seemed to just go by the wayside my
worst one though was the girl that had
panic attacks and like the minute she
conquers the panic attack they kill her
do you remember this one the girl that
was like the doctor i was like oh as
someone that is
similarly affected i was like well
that's not hope
that's a classic walking dead you show
their weakness you show them over a
comment whack
all right so let's talk about couples
though because we're talking about
potentially having babies anyway so
all-time favorite couple who is the
couple that you ship
on walking dead josh makuka easy lori
and shane should have been together the
whole time oh that's a scalding hot take
come on look shane should have never
gone away he was the best character in
the whole show he's the only reason you
kept watching on that dagum farm
and then and then rick wins oh because
i'm supposed to care for why because he
held up the signs at the end of love
actually that's why i'm supposed to like
rick god kept shane he was the man he
had the right idea kill everybody
kill everybody okay jack when the bar
has not been set high for you
favorite couple um i guess glenn and
maggie i mean that's an easy one but i
also and this is not a couple but it is
a pairing and that's carol and daryl
yeah carol and daryl have a love between
them that was
like sort of the seeds were planted
yeah when when when sophia uh was lost
and he brought her the flowers and all
of that like that that was thing there
and like it's still going and it still
has you know a lot of like um
i think weight behind it
uh so i would say carol and daryl
actually i changed my mind they're not a
couple but they're as close to a couple
you can get without sexy that totally
counts i mean i think rick and michonne
had their malt like when they were good
together they were great together in my
opinion i think that one was forced i
thank you jacqueline
no no
forced yes yeah
when they started dating i was like wait
i wanted michonne to get a girl i was
like give me your one of the ladies like
i felt like that would have been i think
michonne and maggie would have been more
believable i'm not gonna say no to that
i'm not gonna say no to that spin-off
but yeah i mean i'm not saying they
didn't have chemistry and it wasn't a
whatever and honestly at that point
neither one of those characters could
date somebody who they're like you may
be zombie meat in a week
it's like the jersey shore house they
all sort of dated at one point but
that's because they were forced into it
via the product their environment right
you eventually rick and somebody had to
hook up he couldn't just focus all of
his attention on killing everybody thank
you
yeah he's got a baby that he stupidly
had with his with his dead wife no
that's shane's baby come on it is
shameful
i also really like carol and ezekiel i
thought that was a sneaky fun
relationship yeah i did enjoy ezekiel
because anytime you have a guy
who's got tigers it's like yeah i'm i'm
now more intrigued in your subplot like
if you're walking down the street and
you meet joshua you're like yeah there's
a nice guy but if you meet joshua cougar
with two tigers
i was cried more for that tiger
then oh my god that tiger died half of
the characters yeah yeah half of the
characters on the show i was like
legitimately upset with that tiger dog
all right but now we have
the real money question here
is
what are the scenes
what are the moments josh if if you have
to pick one walking dead moment that
you're like that's why i love this show
it could be a shocking death could be a
cool zombie kill could be a conversation
what do we think well it's definitely
not a conversation mark as you can tell
i wanted to give you the option well you
could tell via my entire uh angle here
on the show which is kill everybody um
because i listen i was the one that was
always pitching different weapon ideas
on different shows like they just they
didn't use enough cool weapons they were
always trying to like build up walls
just get more weapons from distance
anyway uh okay so it's a very
it's a very like not
remembered scene it it's either when
they blow up terminus which i've already
mentioned but also
when they tie those the cables between
two cars and drive the cars and just
clothesline a million walkers on the
house
and they just chop them in half and it's
just a total bloodbath and i keep
yelling to myself do this more like we
need more of this kill the walkers
and that's yeah there you go
that's pretty that's a pretty great
moment i do like i like a massive
walker dump you know like i like just
getting rid of hundreds of them at the
same time
jacqueline you're the moment that
typifies walking dead
to you
um i mean i already kind of said it with
um we are the walking dead like i said
because this was more of a
a comic holdover for me but carl getting
some uh pudding was pretty dope
i really felt for that kid getting
pudding at that moment
like i really did
that would be what what ended me in the
apocalypse like if i had like a craving
for something and just knowing that like
never don't have it again you're never
going to have it again just bite me
literally
my all-time favorite moment in walking
dead is the first moment that i like i
got i got goosebumps i got chills
because it was just so exciting to see
this manifest even though i was not like
jacqueline and read the comics leading
up to the show
you you could feel the the unification
of folks that came to the show from
watching it on tv and the people who had
been with it since the comic when we got
introduced to michonne because we sort
of had our our core and then we see this
person in the woods with two zombies
behind her chained up
swords the cloak looking very star warsy
and it was just awesome because
i think you can sympathize with this
josh we had seen brutality in the show
up to that point we hadn't seen anything
as ruthless as michonne and so i look at
michonne as like the magic johnson larry
bird of the walking dead where they kind
of revolutionized and made the nba the
modern game what it is michonne made
walking dead something that's going to
continue on and on add well at least
through 11 seasons and a bunch of
spin-off movies as great as the core
characters are that we met in season one
meeting michonne and seeing how excited
everybody that year at comic-con got
anticipating the arrival of that
character was a highlight all time
walking dead for me see here's the thing
with michonne and i called her tediously
tedious early but she is she can be
tedious she can be tedious but i will
say if michonne shows up you know she's
gonna get taken care of okay you know
that like don't leave it up to the bunch
of those other idiots like trying to
figure stuff out whatever just give
michonne a sword and watch her take care
of business it's awesome
hmm
no that's not i'm not going to disagree
i i'd like to niagara and i
yeah i'm happy that you know she got out
i mean this is the thing though as much
as people get mad about who's getting
killed where half the people that got
killed is because they wanted to be yeah
they were like or like they were like we
don't want to be like it's a it's a show
shot in atlanta out in the middle of
nowhere this is not like in the summer
in the summer people have been begging
to be killed off and they just won't do
it so
both in character and probably as the as
the actors so okay i want to ask you all
this as we say goodbye to tv talk before
we transition to behind the scenes the
way that rick left the show
how do we feel about it because it is
sort of this epic thing where rick i
mean he gets impaled
you know
miraculously avoided most of his major
organs he's just getting the crap beat
out of him and then he finds himself on
this helicopter flying
somewhere so it is so open-ended which
gives us the opportunity to have these
rick grimes possibly movie spin off so
we'll talk about in a sec but did y'all
just like that not anticipating what
could happen in film later on just as
they send off to rick was that the way
rick should have gone out or should he
have just been properly killed off or
should he still just be alive leading a
group to this day
i mean it depends on how good they make
it if the candle's worth the flame
okay
i feel like if you were gonna if
you still got judith coral's dead okay
little badass judith is still doing her
thing
i at least think at least it kind of
gave us a look to an outside world that
is possible like with a helicopter
because i'm so tired of it just being
this
world like i would have loved to see
more world building like bigger
sets different people like an actual
culture instead of legit just fighting
for the same alexandria
it it got a little tedious so if that
opens up the world to like a little more
rick grimes doing something else sign me
up for it i want to see it yeah i i feel
like this show is at its best when it is
it's on a good pace with expanding the
world and i think that's where a lot of
people maybe even when jacqueline and i
just started to fall off where it's like
we felt like we were building towards
something and then we it's like that
dream where
like i have to get to stage because i
have a show and there's an audience
waiting for me and i just it's like
spinal tap i can't find my way out of
the green room and i keep trying to
figure out a way and i just can't it's
like just get to the stage just get to
the stage like just get to alexandria
get to wherever we're trying to go in
that season and let's as they would say
in the great young guns too finish the
game so that finishes tv talk but now
we're gonna go into some
behind-the-scenes stuff and talk about
possibly some optimism for the future of
walking dead and its many spin-offs hit
the music
[Music]
yeah so this
let's let's start with the carol and
daryl spinoff because after season 11
we're gonna get this carol darrell
spin-off with fear the walking dead is
already a
fairly successful spin-off i'd say might
get spin-off movies all of these things
that are possible in the walking dead
universe which
gets josh mccooga most excited
uh i tried to watch the first season of
fear of the walking dead and it felt
like a lot of the same
um so i was kind of like bummed by that
uh
in in the sense of like it's just
another small group of people against
bad villains that are the they survived
kind of a thing and
um so i mean carol darrell smith
truth be told i just want to see those
rick movies i want to know what happens
rick i want to see this bigger world so
if you're going to invest in it and
you're going to give us andrew lincoln
who we've already invested nine plus
seasons in
i i you have to want to see those rick
movies
i am
and after revisiting this and catching
up on some of the seasons that i had
fallen off on and like getting to know
what exactly happened to rick i'm very
intrigued not just with the rick movies
that are coming out jacqueline but
whether there is some hope for rick
appearing at the end of season 11 which
is the final season of the walking dead
do we get to see rick one more time on
the tv show i mean i think so like they
got to do that like i think it would be
i think they have people like
legitimately pissed i think it's gonna
be like you know
everybody dies in the
on six feet under like they're really
gonna try and tie this up with a bow
especially after they fell off for those
couple of seasons but i think a lot of
that has to do with too like to be true
the comics fell off at certain points
during that like the comics had a real
like gully where where things went
really kind of crazy and actually the
show coming on revitalize that because
the comics were seven years deep when
the show came on and around the time
that the show came on is when the comics
actually kicked back up into high gear
after a bit of a gully i would say in
not enjoyment but just people being as
invested
interesting yeah yeah i i i'm very
excited to start to to pick back up and
watch season 11. josh if you want to
have the parties i know you live on the
good side of hollywood now with
jacqueline and i so yeah um you can host
us and i and i think jacqueline are you
gonna watch season 11 like real time
because i'm like i'm fully backed in i'm
pumped
i mean
in theory i would i would say that my
want and desire to watch it is great but
as you know mark i turn into a pumpkin
in about four weeks
uh
and the only thing i'm watching once we
get into september is movies that might
get a trophy mama gets busy mama gets
very big
let me give you the truth i still have
not seen the mandalorian
oh wow the mandalorian comes out in
december y'all the mandalorian comes out
in december december i am thinking about
oscars and so it is very hard to like
turn down the oscar shortlist which i'm
literally paid to watch to be like i'm
gonna go watch pablo pascal with a
helmet on i want to
i want to
but he looks good in the helmet he looks
like he does look i mean
i know the show is great
i literally have you know people that
i'm very close to are upset that i've
watched the show pedro pascal pedro did
i say pablo it did that's his brother
he's a classical guitarist okay there
you go thank you i made that up really
yeah i'm like i don't know
uh bringing it back to walking dead or
fear the walking dead i'm a big reuben
blades fan who's a good musician yes
josh what can we expect in season 11. i
want the official josh mccooga
prediction for what we're going to see
in season 11 who's making it out who's
not what's gonna happen what's going
down season 11 from josh makuka it's
such like a it's such a weird hard
prediction because
you're so spread out now and uh you know
you got people locked in trains you have
uh
others just kind of wandering around
you've got the maggie negan thing you've
got people trying to rescue other people
i feel like
we're somehow going to get to somewhere
where there's an actual civilization
right and they're going to actually be
assimilated in somewhere to like
a city i don't know if it gets to like
some part of the world has actually been
working towards something and they're
bringing on good people to try and keep
that
i again
ending after 11 seasons like this so
open-ended would be the walking dead
way to do it um but do you want to see
that or do you want because i like neat
resolutions and i feel like fans who've
been hanging with this show for all 11
seasons deserve that or maybe they don't
want that maybe that's why they've stuck
around all these seasons is that they
love the open-ended they just want to
speculate ad nauseam forevermore about
what the file from season 11 was yeah
because that's so much fun for sopranos
fans
um
hey you get a prequel now you're getting
yeah you can sequel movies so walking
dead so it just opens the door for more
potential i'll be honest with you if i
was in that writer's room i'd be
stressed out yeah also one thing with
the soprano prequel i don't want to
judge it because this is actually a film
that's a little bit in my world even
though it's tv but it's going to be a
new york film festival i would think
that that movie i assumed would be
opening new york film festival because
it's like the most new york thing like
sopranos and it got beaten out by a
black and white
macbeth
which makes me think that that movie may
not have the goods david chase i don't
know
it's for some reno's fans it's a fan
service it's awesome y'all ever been to
uh to i think it's sanoya it's like
outside of atlanta where they film the
majority of the walking dead it is the
whole town it's just this tiny town and
christian rubel cabba our engineer and i
got on assignment there one time so we
spent a weekend hosting this event for
hardcore walking dead fans we went
around to a lot of the locations where
they had filmed up to that point i think
christian if i'm not mistaken i think it
was to kick off season five i think is
what we were hosting that event for and
so we were like just taking people
around taking pictures and it was so
much fun meeting like the townsfolk and
how excited they are because that town's
whole economy is the walking dead
there's a restaurant that norman reedus
and i think greg nicotero owned together
where everybody eats on like the one
main street and it's kind of awesome
being right there
i mean i would love it i love any kind
of like film back any little town that's
just
made by this it's like gilmore girls why
wouldn't you want to live in gilmore
girls same seems amazing you know
i i i
go to hobbiton but it's fine yeah or
like uh croatia where they shot game of
thrones or newark new jersey no don't go
to newark not nice
and i spent many a uh a good time in
newark new jersey including a wedding
where i stayed at the newark airport
hilton all right that is gonna do it for
our behind the scenes of the walking
dead and now it's time for mailbag
[Music]
that's right josh people write us people
love our show so much they write us and
so we give them a beloved name the
ketchup crew and this is from our member
of the ketchup crew michael kessen and
michael says i usually check the score
for a movie on rotten tomatoes before i
see it but i did not for this movie
meet joe black
the reimagined film of death takes a
holiday was a movie i thoroughly enjoyed
and i heavily disagree with the 45
splat i'd love to see you guys talk
about this love you guys
all right round table on meet joe black
look i love meet joe black not because
i've ever seen the whole movie but
because i paid to see that movie so i
could watch the first trailer for star
wars episode one the phantom menace
black will forever hold a special spot
in my heart josh jacqueline have we seen
meet joe black is it worth talking about
uh we're definitely worth talking about
uh brad pitt's uh jamaican patois in
that movie
seriously i really hope they pull up the
audio clip because brad pitt and his
legends of the fall
90s awesomeness literally sounds like
chet hanks in the middle of that movie
please play the sound
have you seen meet y'all
black are you i haven't seen michael
black and i love like
heartfelt claire for lonnie a very
underrated actress
um
i
i i 45 is low i mean that's like josh
makuga favorite movie level low so um
i i think rotten tomatoes might have it
wrong there it's just it's a solid
heartfelt movie with a very coy uh naive
brad pitt that's kind of lovely it's
sort of like phenomenon with john
travolta yeah i love phenomenon
i did not expect that answer coming out
of joshua cougar's mouth you have
impressed me sir you have grown so much
since i first discovered you in a
dumpster outside the laugh factory
you're doing no problem so many that's
actually josh and i met at the laugh
factory like three in the morning uh way
back when even before the walking dead
premiered so josh i knew you'd be a
great guest you did not disappoint and i
think that we all did a great thing
today going through 10 seasons of
walking dead these are thick seasons too
these are seasons like season
five a and season five b so japan did a
great job tonight episodes it's amazing
tv it's on tv it's a crap ton of tv and
i know that you for whatever reason josh
are you so you don't get scared watching
walking dead because i know you get
scared at everything very few jump
scares in the walking dead like yeah
they'll get me on a few jump scares here
and there but like every time a zombie
is coming you can hear them because
you're just like
right and you know they're coming out of
nowhere like look inside that door
there's going to be a
there they are all right well i'm still
not sitting next to you for the big uh
rick grimes movie walking dead i just
don't trust it yet with you
in a theater for a horror movie but i do
uh love you dearly as a friend where can
everybody find all the good stuff you're
doing at the gpa all the other cool
things you have in your life not the
least of which is your beyond adorable
daughter who needs even more instagram
time than she already gets she's amazing
and you're doing a great job as a new
dad oh thank you yeah she she's uh
almost six months now uh she's already
watched bad boys too and she is just the
biggest fan as me
we'll have you back on for our bad boys
2 episode i promise thank you thank you
uh yeah at joshua cougar twitter and
instagram good people gpa the youtube
youtube.com c the good people
association the positivity reports every
single morning 9 a.m pacific and then
josh purdy every friday live at 2pm mark
is there tomorrow with christian harloff
first time they've been on camera
together in the same room in a long time
yeah yeah my my old friend now nemesis
on josh predi christian horowath um
is do you have a like a movie or
streaming recommendation for us you're
not allowed to pick bad boys too and
you're not allowed to say just watch
jeopardy i'm putting handcuffs on you oh
i don't know if you can do that there's
a lot of drama with droppity right now
yeah got one host and now you have
multiple hosts and this is nobody's
happy about either josh
[Music]
josh what did i what did i tell you
because josh had been campaigning
forever that he would like to host
jeopardy whenever alice trebek did
decide to step away josh wanted to
succeed him and i think this is setting
up perfectly for you because what i told
you is that whoever has to follow trebek
it's an impossible task you can't follow
at your back and so you just have to
follow the people that followed trebek
and this is just setting up all things
are turning up makuga in the world of
jeopardy i just want you to know that
life is a long time
it's futility mark it's the actual game
of living um
the uh
if i was going to recommend something
right now
a lot of good streaming movies uh it's
hard to watch a movie with my wife who
doesn't have the same taste as me and
movies but we can binge tv shows and i
will say the best sketch comedy show
since kian peel is i think you should
leave on netflix with tim robinson it is
by far the funniest thing that netflix
has put out and if i i would be
appalled if i didn't mention ted lasso
it's my favorite show on tv correct that
is a show that i could accurately
predict you watching walking dead that
one still throws me for a curveball
just a little bit we love when our fans
chime in when they come along with us
for the conversation and if you want to
be like our steam member of the ketchup
crew michael kessen you can email us at
rt is wrong rottentomatoes.com that's rt
is wrong at rottentomatoes.com let us
know a movie a tv show that you want us
to talk through and let us know your
thoughts on the movies and tv shows we
have discussed on the program whether
you're watching us whether you're
listening to us subscribe hit the stars
rate review whatever your provider of
choice asks you to do with podcast
please do it for us because we love you
so show that you love us jacqueline next
week we got a big big movie it's a
little out of season for this movie but
when it's a great romantic comedy you
can never get too far away from the
season of giving i'm a firm believer
this one is never out of season we're
taking a trip we're getting on a plane
and we're going to nancy meyers the
holiday with a very special guest
uh for any of you doctor who fans gets
right we got i think one of the most
beloved companions billy piper she's on
there with us for that episode where she
also defends
its honor it's a great episode can't
wait for you you don't want to move to
the english countryside after that movie
there's something wrong with you
seriously perfect oh yeah all right so
me jacqueline billy piper lucy and now
we might add josh to zoom this movie
mark you know me i love a good rom-com
i've never not liked a rom-com ever i
know and every rom-com you've ever seen
has elicited full-on weeping from this
young man he's emotional he's italian
he's from pittsburgh he is joshua
hercules-makuga for him lucy bruckner
the great engineer christian rival cabo
and hey brian perez we miss you you're
coming back soon my wonderful co-host
and the synopsis queen of all synopsis
jacqueline coley i am merely mark ellis
for the entire crew here on tomatoes
that's a walker and i hope they don't
bite me have a great one we'll see y'all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you